whoa destructive wins record storm surge
and in some places up to 30 centimeters
of rain that fell in just 12 to 24 hours
another record breaker
we got out the door swam out the doors
the water was here
and then we got over onto this
and then we walked our way around the
whole side of the house from the roof
line
and then swam over to that pontoon boat
the storm is different it broke all the
rules that we've been here a really long
time my chimney came down I was afraid
it was going to come through the roof
and crush me
and now in its wake the search for those
who survived and those that didn't there
have been more than 700 confirmed
rescues and there's likely many more
than that that will be confirmed as more
data comes in the president toured in
the agency that deals with disasters
warned the death toll could be shocking
this could be the deadliest hurricane in
Florida's history
the numbers of still are still unclear
but we're hearing early reports of what
may be substantial loss of life that
would put the number of dead over 2 000
and it's going to take a while to find
out the true scale of the disaster the
lone bridge to Sanibel Island had large
chunks washed away and many roads are
still unpassable and it's not over we
are expecting the storm to continue
making its way to Georgia South Carolina
and into North Carolina maintaining
tropical storm force winds deadly storm
surge and rainfall of up to 12 inches a
historic storm that experts say was made
Stronger by warming Waters now people
all across Florida are seeing the true
costs of climate change Patty culhane Al
Jazeera